[Musique]
le ciel ne se dégage toujours pas pour
l'industrie du transport aérien Air
Transat annonce la fermeture de ces
installations Vancouver pour centraliser
ces opérations dans l'est du pays la
décision va toucher 192 agents de bord 7
pilotes un gestionnaire qui doivent
maintenant choisir entre quitter
l'entreprise ou s'installer à Toronto ou
à Montréal avec nous pour faire le tour
de plusieurs actualités dans le secteur
John Gradec professeur de gestion de
l'aviation à l'université de migil
bonsoir Monsieur Gradec
bonsoir Andréane alors on va parler de
d'abord du recentrage des activités de
transat il y a pas de perte d'emploi à
proprement parler là selon l'entreprise
le programme de vol d'ailleurs va rester
le même pour le moment alors comment on
explique cette décision
au niveau de leur opération canadienne
on réduit assez
fermement leur service avant couvert ils
ont seulement 4 volts par semaine qui
ont peur entre Toronto Montréal et
Vancouver d'abord la présence de Air
Transat avant couvert diminué de
beaucoup et je pense qu'avec une
installation des individus à une base
opérationnelle on doit surtout penser où
sont les opérations et comment vraiment
mettre les effectifs en fonction et ils
avaient trop d'effectif effectués
centralisation était leur option
primaire d'ailleurs même si on a observé
pendant la période des fêtes un
engouement là qui a repris pour les
voyages transat dizaines à son dernier
rapport annuel attention il y a encore
des incertitudes importantes qui
demeurent considérant la capacité à
poursuivre les activités en 2023 est-ce
qu'on doit s'inquiéter pour l'entreprise
monsieur radec
je pense je pense que si on regarde la
performance de transat pendant les fêtes
surtout les fêtes qu'on avait se passer
je pense que dans l'ensemble des
transporteurs Canadiens un transat c'est
au dessus de tout le monde je pense
qu'au nom de retard et nombre de
l'annulation ça se compare même pas
qu'est-ce que
comparé à d'autres compagnies aériennes
d'abord je pense que la compagnie est
bien gérée qu'ils ont vraiment un plan
d'action que du bon sens et je pense que
ici il y a une question de de
performance ça va être le marché est-ce
que le marché va être là pour les
services qui vont offrir pendant l'été
donc vous semblez suggérer que transat
fait mieux que d'autres peut-être mieux
que Sunwing certainement l'entreprise a
annoncé cette semaine l'annulation de
presque tous ses vols en partance de
reginal la moitié des vols hivernaux qui
partent de saskato aussi qu'est-ce qui
se passe chez Sunwing
et ils ont aussi annoncé aujourd'hui
l'annulation de leurs services entre
Winnipeg et l'oscarons
une réduction de services qui réduit ce
faire il y a quelques mois je pense que
avec l'annulation de leur approbation
pour l'embauche depuis pilote
internationaux ils ont eu
une nécessité vraiment nécessaire de
d'avoir une réduction de leurs services
ils l'ont pas fait pendant les fêtes et
on a des casiers ont subi des
conséquences de cette hausse de service
sans boire et puis l'autre d'abord c'est
vraiment
une chose que j'aurais dû faire il y a
quelques mois mais on prend les
conséquences aujourd'hui d'abord une
annulation on n'a pas fini avec ouais
c'est ça les conséquences c'est aussi
les plaintes il y en a eu plus de 5000
pour les vols retardés ou annulés
pendant la période des fêtes et
maintenant la grogne est importante en
plus chez les gens de Régina chez les
gens de saskatum qui avait des
réservations pour les prochaines
semaines est-ce que est-ce que ces
tâches à la réputation de Sunwing de
faire mal à l'entreprise
absolument je pense que la valeur du
marché de Sunwing et la marque de
Sunwing a beaucoup été affecté parce que
avec les événements de
semaine je pense que les Canadiens ont
vraiment une résistance maintenant à
acheter des billets de Sunwing et ça
peut vraiment c'est quoi la façon qui
vont opérer d'abord c'est vraiment une
marque contre Sunwing et on espère que
c'est pas vraiment la fin de Sunwing on
a besoin de transporteur à peu près
comme Sunwing mais malheureusement les
actions des gestionnaires de somewhing
n'a pas aidé à gérer la marque cet égard
donc est-ce qu'on doit aller jusqu'à
crème pour sa survie monsieur Gradec
absolument absolument
et ça
pourrait même qu'on promettre mon le
projet d'ouest jet là qui souhaiterait
acheter l'entreprise même si le Bureau
de la concurrence évidemment a émis
certaines réserves est-ce que WestJet
pourrait même se montrer moins intéressé
ou plutôt l'acheter un meilleur prix
absolument
de la perte de valeur de la compagnie il
y a une définition de l'innovation
négociation je dois faire de nouveau
avec la valeur que
représente pour
WestJet et même il y a question que
WestJet
d'abandonner l'achat de ce moyen d'abord
on les change sont bonnes que quelque
chose qui va se passer avec Sunwing
d'une façon de là je pense pas que la
marque va durer beaucoup plus que
quelques mois mais c'est vrai
ce sera un grand bouleversement dans le
secteur si ça se produit il nous reste
quelques secondes monsieur Gradel je
vous entendre il manque de pilote ça
aide pas le transport aérien ça
je pense qu'on voit une croissance dans
le nombre de transporteurs au Canada et
c'est transporteur ont vraiment besoin
depuis avec ces nouveaux appareils ils
ont embauché deux sans pilotes dans les
deux dernières dans les dernières 5 mois
et on prend une misère à trouver des
pilotes je pense vraiment une question
c'est vraiment une question de salaire
et de voir que l'épilation disponibles
c'est vraiment une question de s'assurer
que les salariés sont là excellent merci
beaucoup pour votre analyse encore une
fois Monsieur cradec merci Madame
bonsoir pour voir nos émissions en
entier rendez-vous sur la chaîne ici RDI